extra dirty of course you do you
filthy girls so an extra dirty martini
people over here what you want to rap
about science fiction give me more
something more specific
star wars was even more specific
great jabba the hutt a very dirty
martini middle of the room what do you
want to wrap about
okay um are you
may i ask if you're from mexico city
where we're from texas well that again
i don't feel your two regions have a
great relationship do they
but the rule is i have to take what is
suggested if it's never been suggested
before and clearly that's never come up
before because
a it happened yesterday and two no one
is a sadistic vindictive bully
what do you want to wrap about over here
law school
great uh and over here what do you want
to rap about darwin
darwin oh is there any particular aspect
of darwin that isn't his theory of
evolution that you're interested in
okay finches very good if you didn't
know about that the finch is pretty
exciting okay so
darwin and his finches law school the
overpass collapsing in mexico city a
very dirty martini and jabba the hutt
this then lovely people are the comedy
still it's a freestyle rap that's a wrap
made up on the spot based entirely on
suggestions not written not prepared not
rehearsed and do not worry it will not
be anywhere near as atrociously
embarrassingly toe-curlingly bad as
you're expecting a privately educated
middle class white boy to be
if we can drop that beat dj let's get
this uh let's get this going
and crank it a little bit as well that's
what i'm talking about
yeah i like it i like it
you gotta pick it up there's only one
left to live if i order a martini don't
hold the olive
i need a lot of juice in the high glass
i wanna pick it from the bar when i
glide past
like james bond the bartender says yes
sir originally the martini that was
called the vespa mix it with the bitter
driver mouth
i prefer the gin rather vodka that's the
truth the guy started clapping over
there trying to provide the beat after
you sip on the martini all of you can
eat maybe get three on a little cocktail
stick
call me cromulus prom yeah cause i'm
sick i know i got the name slightly
wrong you adore you be george lucas
lover when you're watching star wars
see them on the barge there by the kit
see boba fett trying to get out of the
[ __ ] why
cause jabba the hot looks like the back
of a mop he's all brown and his skin's
so much
old he's basically in the star wars
universe a gangster he be training
everybody just the two of us
know the movies all these guys are
afraid go into galapagos and spend my
days on the back of a ship i'm with
charles we go
by the first names why because darwin's
my bro i could talk about
evolution natural selection but check
out all the finches on the closer
inspection on the island you can see
they're all related but at some point in
time
they deviated the length of the beak and
the width of the wing
i studied anthropology so this is my
thing and it's okay though
i know it really rules at least it's
less dry than the law school but more so
than the martini we said it at the start
if you wanna get passing the bar you
best be smart
it's an art to do that it kicks ass
unlike the man with the mexican overpass
he's like yeah we american check us i
don't get to overpass crumbling in texas
we got great roads
mexicans [ __ ] you bad and invest 2 billy
in the infrastructure but i instructure
to be more empathetic
sure the infrastructure might be
pathetic but a lot of people die i
believe it's 23 and probably is gonna
rise exponentially there you go
lovely people thank you very much my
name is chris turner good night goodbye